Vsauce Michael here with a special treat
for you today it's a guy named Jerry
blue who's never played a video game in
his life but yet reviews them anyway
played by a real person named Kevin who
does play video games and has a great
channel right over here he's already
made a few uninformed video game reviews
so check this one out it's the first one
he made he made it back in June I hope
you enjoy greetings on the Internet
realm jerry bloop here with uninformed
video game reviews the series where i
review video games that I've never
played because I have no money of my own
and I don't know where my mom is
today is June since this is the first
video of uninformed video game reviews
there might be a few kinks to work out
so bear with me while I figure this out
all right first of all I forgot pants
all right now that I have pants on let's
get the uninformed reviews started the
first game is Mario Galaxy 2 which is
for the Nintendo Wii Nestene oisin it's
also known as Mario eight and contains
all the plumbing action that you've
loved since you were wearing diapers
last year in this game you get to
collect coins and stars and you get to
jump on mean Turtles and you have to
kill the main turtle who's a demon king
turtle and save the queen of peaches
luckily you get your own nice turtle to
ride on name sushi it's great game that
you should play and let me know how it
is because I don't have it the next game
is called blur and it's multi console
it's for the Sony three and also the
icebox 360 it's a car game where you
play as Gary the car and you have to
destroy the evil cars as deemed by the
great car council and save all car town
I've never driven a car before but I did
drive my neighbor Geoffrey's power
wheels once but I crashed it into his
dad's real car and I'm not allowed over
there anymore another brand-new game -
video game land is trauma team which is
come out for the Nintendo Wii nice penis
and you play as a team of doctors who
has to fix body parts mostly boobs I
don't know much about boobs so why don't
you tell me about trauma team but
actually talk about boobs that way my
mom won't figure out we're talking about
boobs and I won't get in trouble
actually she's usually drunk so she
won't know the difference anyway so play
the game tell me about it
but mostly let's talk boobs the final
game this month is Red Dead Redemption
it's made by the same guys who did Grand
Theft Auto it's on Sony 3 and icebox and
it's amazing game it's a first cowboy
video game in forever o clock in this
game you can shoot people which is scary
you can ride horses which is scarier and
you can talk to girls which is a
nightmare made out of nightmares it
looks like a great game and I'd love to
play it so why don't you tell me about
it instead because I can all right now
it's time for the part of the show
called game life is real life or I try
out something from a video game to see
if it really works today I'm going to
try eating mushrooms like Mario to see
if I get bigger because I can't ride on
rollercoasters
luckily I found some mushrooms
underneath my sister's mattress so I'll
eat these and see if it works
here we go
even if nothing Mario likes gross food
oh I'm sorry
there's coins down there I can get coins
I can buy all the video games are one
alright coins here I come
well the mushrooms didn't work I can get
bigger but I sure got smellier that's it
for this month's episode keep playing
video games because I can't
good bye internet realm ah he saws thank
you so much for watching the first
episode of uninformed video game reviews
it's kind of a weird show but that's
what I'm all about
so come and check out my channel and
then subscribe then pat yourself on the
back because you just won the Olympics
of the Internet I gotta go
you